Let us look at the solution for
our reliability and availability quiz.
We had the hard disk that had
three working periods and
three broken periods
until we threw it away.
The mean time to failure is how long
it works on average before it breaks.
We had it working for 12 and
then four and then 14 months.
So on average,
it worked 12 + 4 + 14 months,
divided by 3,
because there were 3 figures in between.
And this gives us 30/3 which is 10,
so the answer here is 10 months.
For our mean time to repair,
it's how long does it take to
repair it after a failure?
And we had a one month, a two month and
the three month repair period.
So our MTTR is simply 1
+ 2 + 3 over 3 because
we need the average of these three
which ends up being two months.
And finally the availability
is what percentage of time
was this disk in service
over the entire period.
We can compute this in two ways.
One is what's the main time to failure
divided by main time
to failure plus MTTR.
Which gives us ten months of service
on average over ten plus two
months of both service and repair.
This is ten over 12 or 83.33%.
Another way to compute availability
is to add up all the months that we
were in service and divide them by
the sum of all the months together.
In that case, we will get 30 months of
service divided by those same 30 months
plus the six months of repair,
which is 30 over 36.
And this again gives us
our 83.33% availability.